encore une dizaine de jours après il ne
sera plus obligatoire presque deux ans
plus tard la santé publique va annoncer
demain la fin du port du masque dans les
lieux publics aller chez la coiffeuse
j'aimerais que comporte une messe dans
des foules compactes de garde est sans
doute un terme à l'épicerie l'ailé les
autobus est sûre je regarde moi j'ai
jamais eu aucun problème avec sur le
port du masque va toutefois demeuré
obligatoire dans les transports en
commun et dans les établissements de
santé pour l'hôpital à mon humble avis
on reporte encore longtemps les patients
qu'aux villes demeurent nombreux dans
les hôpitaux le virus à changer les
moeurs on veut se protéger comme je
disais le gastro entérite influence
decaux vide on actuellement virus ces
temps ci aux urgences qu'on va continuer
à le porter pendant discuter en colère
puis on se dit justement que dorénavant
on portait toujours la main je pense en
travaillant on choisira pas les 95
personnes infectées à la coved sont
hospitalisés la courbe est à la baisse
mais dans la capitale nationale
il y à 232 patients qu'ovide un plateau
semble atteint les hospitalisations ne
sont pas idéales présentement on a
beaucoup de personnes encore dans les
hôpitaux à travers la province le
docteur veine émet des doutes sur la fin
du port du masque obligatoire pour lui
la coved l'a bien démontré difficile de
prédire le futur d'ici le 14 mai tout
est possible avec le virus j'ai mes
assiettes figure buste promettrait
quelque chose dans l'avenir parce que
dans l'amertume et dans la science rien
n'est garanti la santé publique vont
aussi recommandé aux plus vulnérables de
garder le masque mais tout n'est pas
encore décidée perpignan c'est encore en
discussion
les gestionnaires de résidences privées
pour aînés qui donnent des soins
souhaite le métier du masque mais c'est
une autre histoire pour les rpa avec des
résidants autonomes en visant rue paul
louis deux sens peu les gens des menaces
qu'on en est le masque donc on préfère
évidemment enlevé le masque pour les
résidences autonome le port du masque
est obligatoire au québec dans les lieux
publics depuis le 18 juillet 2020 c'est
demain à 11 heures que le docteur
boileau va annoncer la fin de cette
mesure phare de la pandémie ici pierre
alexandre bolduc radio canada québec